Over the last 20 years, Israel
has become a tech powerhouse.
They often refer to
Israel as startup nation.
Well, this is pretty
cool, one of the companies
that got start here,
Waze, you all know Waze,
it's how we all get around.
Waze started in Israel, they're in
that building right there, let's go.
Well this is pretty impressive,
I've gone right to the top,
I'm talking to Guy and Fej, Guy,
you are the Chief Operating
Officer here at Waze?
Yeah.
And Fej, first employee at Waze, right?
After the founders.
After the founders, yes, of course
and then you just saw the
thing and you hung on.
Is that right?
That's right.
You've just been kissing ass
since day one, haven't you?
You have quite an impressive operation.
Are these people working right now
or are they all mostly
watching pornography?
How's it work?
What's happening here?
Are you working on a specific problem?
Where is this area that you're looking at?
You're just working on your route home?
There's a whole world
out there that wants help
and this guy is just
working on his route home.
Oh yeah.
I bet you tell people
there's a traffic jam
when there isn't, so
they go a different way
and you have an easy commute.
Have a quick question, why is the redhead
forced to sit in the back all by himself?
This is the kind of prejudice that
I've been fighting since day one.
Hey brother.
You should know it too.
Oh, exactly, yes.
Has any of you ever
invited this guy to lunch?
Invite him to lunch, he's a person too!
Maybe you can invite me sometime.
That's not gonna happen.
They did a beautiful artwork of me there,
they took, is that the Wazer guy
and you turned him into me,
that's just very nice of you.
I look like a very shy sperm.
I look like a sperm that isn't confident
he's gonna fertilize anyone.
Ah well, I missed out this
time, maybe next time.
Is that a child?
I hear a child.
This is terrible, they have
no humanity here at Waze.
They're putting children to work.
There are laws!
Alright, can I have
everyone's attention please,
this will just take a second.
I love Waze, I think
Waze is an amazing app.
But I do have one complaint, my kids,
they like this restaurant
called, Milo and Olive, okay?
It's in Santa Monica, we go down
Pacific Palisades, everything's
going fine, we work our way down.
Then you guys have me
take a right, right here,
on 14th Street, terrific,
with you all the way, Waze.
Then you guys want me to
take a left on Montana.
There is no light, you can't make a left,
and then my wife's like
saying, "go now, go now."
and I'm like, "I can't go
now, there's a car coming."
who's the person here,
who's gonna make sure
I don't have to take, who is it?
She ran away?
You can't run from me!
I came all the way to Tel Aviv!
This is Los Angeles, this is the
Western part of Los Angeles and basically,
I'm gonna review very quickly.
My kids, there's this restaurant called,
Milo and Olive, they like it there...
Turkey meatball and that's lean protein,
which I like, you get good
salads, the wife likes.
The problem is, everything's going great
until I have to take this left.
If you could solve this problem
for me, that would be huge.
Consider it solved.
Who do I call when I have a personal
traffic jam that I need to take care of?
Is it okay if that's you?
I can be the one.
Okay, there's the big time change.
So I'll be calling you a lot like in
three in the morning, four in the morning.
I'll be awake.
Okay, so this is gonna
be your personal number.
Okay.
And you're not gonna
get paid extra for this?
Nope.
Okay, this is just
something you have to do
for the rest of your life,
even after you leave Waze
and go onto another business
or start your own company.
You swear to do this for
the rest of your life?
I do.
Oh my god.
Thank you so much.